la muerte de su majestad la reina es un
gran golpe a la nación y al mundo entero
la reina elisabeth segunda fue una roca
sobre la cual se construyó la gran
batalla moderna nuestro país ha crecido
y ha florecido bajo su reinado de gran
bretaña es el gran país que es hoy por
ella
inició su reinado después gráfico de
cree mundial lideró el desarrollo de la
commonwealth desde un pequeño grupo de
siete países a una familia de 56
naciones
que llegan a cada continente del
movimiento ahora somos una nación
moderna dinámica poderosa
la estabilidad y el poder que
necesitábamos
fue el verdadero espíritu de gran
bretaña y ese espíritu perdurará
ha sido nuestra monarca con el reinado
más largo este gran logro
de presidir contra dignidad y gracias
durante 70 años su vida de servicios
la mayoría de nuestros recuerdos
históricos ella fue amada al revés o
amada por todo el mundo también
felicitaciones precio personal para mí
que para muchas británicas su devoción
al deber es un ejemplo para todos
nosotros
temprano esta semana a los 96 años y
seguía determinada con cumplir con sus
tareas así medida que me nombraba como
su primer ministro número 15 en su vida
ha visto más de 100 países y tocó las
vidas de millones alrededor del mundo
es difícil escribir en nos reuniremos
con nuestros amigos en todo el reino
unido la commonwealth y el resto del
mundo para celebrar su vida
extraordinaria de servicio
es un día en el que sentimos una grave
pérdida
la reina isabel segunda deja un gran
legado
y hoy la corona se pasa de un miembro a
otro como ha sido por más de mil años a
nuestro nuevo monarca nuestro nuevo jefe
de estado su majestad el rey carlos
tercero con la familia del rey
lamentamos la pérdida de su madre ya
medida que vimos eso vivimos nuestro
luto nos reunimos como pueblo para
ayudarlo para ayudarle a sostener esa
responsabilidad que carga en nombre de
todos nosotros le ofrecemos nuestra
lealtad y nuestra devoción
así como su madre fue tan devota a tanto
a tantos por tanto tiempo
y con el paso de esta segunda era
isabelina entramos a una nueva etapa de
la historia magnífica nuestro país
exactamente como nos dio su majestad o
hubiera deseado al decir nuestras
palabras dios salve rey